semiconductors
are tiny chips that make practically
every single digital technology we see
today
possible and in the 1990s europe not the
united states or south korea was the
leader in charge of producing them
it had a market share of 44 the united
states had 37
and south korea 19. and this
distribution
was mainly the result of the early
success of european mobile phone
companies
like ericsson nokia and siemens but
known to many this position
was short-lived over the past couple of
decades
european mobile phone companies lost
their dominant early positions
and semiconductor markets were largely
outsourced due to reductions in labor
costs
today in 2021 europe sits on around an 8
to 10 percent market share
while china taiwan and south korea own
24
21 and 19 respectively compared to the
1990s
europe's position today is a lot less
and europe is currently taking steps
to regain some of its previous position
by setting a goal
for a 20 market share for semiconductor
manufacturing
by 2030 and this goal represents more
than simply achieving
a larger portion of chip production
europe's aim
with boosting manufacturing for
semiconductors represents one puzzle
piece
of a much larger goal europe's strategic
autonomy
a european goal to reduce reliance on
external countries
and strengthen its ability to defend
itself
semiconductors are the building blocks
of every single digital technology
we see today and this means that when
semiconductor manufacturing
faces a supplier to manage shock like
we're currently seeing right now
it can ripple through multiple lucrative
industries that affects consumers
if those supply shocks are nationally
delineated countries can scream that
they've become overly reliant on
entities located outside of their
borders
for instance tsmc a single taiwanese
chip manufacturing company
is responsible for manufacturing about
92 percent of the world's
most sophisticated microchips and helps
produce 90
of the chips that are used by apple
amazon google
qualcomm nvidia and amd so
if something geopolitically contentious
were to occur in a place like taiwan
i don't know that's just an example that
could have severe ramifications
for other industries and ripples way
down multiple supply chains
and it's abundantly clear that this
dynamic is one of the main causes of
europe trying to consolidate
semiconductor manufacturing
cheki bhutan the european commissioner
for the internal market
who has been spearheading the eu's
investment in semiconductors has stated
do we europe want to be in the driving
seat of the digital transformation
or be subject to the choices of others
do we want europe to lead and set our
own rules
or accept to be a simple bystander with
political will
and industrial commitment we can make
sure that europe is back on the
semiconductor
race if this doesn't sound like a state
representative
attempting to reduce reliance external
to their state's borders i don't know
what is
but there also seems to be other
intentions besides reducing
vulnerability to supply chain
disruptions
for example it's not just that the eu
wants to increase the supply of chips on
home soil
but the eu has made it clear they want
to produce the most advanced
semiconductors on the planet
currently europe's largest industries do
not need highly advanced semiconductors
because most major consumer electronics
companies are located in the us
and the auto sector in europe which is
strong is not in need of such extremely
advanced semiconductors
the fact that europe would be pushing
for producing the most advanced
semiconductors
means that it's not just focused on
having enough chips when supply chains
are disrupted
it means that europe is also aiming to
increase its chance for grabbing onto
future growth
and being a more powerful piece of that
supply chain
however as always talking about the eu's
aims
is fundamentally different than talking
about what is possible
semiconductors as you could probably
assume are not cheap
and setting up manufacturing factories
takes a lot of time and money
one thing governments are notoriously
good at though is throwing lots of money
at big problems
and the money that is being prepared to
be thrown over the next decade
seems to be a lot from 2000 to 2020
china had around 50 billion in direct
incentives for manufacturing
semiconductors
south korea had 7 7-10 taiwan 0.5
europa bid over 2.5 and the united
states of course had zero
but in 2021 it seems like countries are
feeling the need to spend their stimulus
checks
and south korea has become an obvious
leader pledging 450 billion over a
decade
the u.s senate has passed 50 billion but
the eu has pledged more than the u.s
a whopping 150 billion dollars in
investment which will obviously coincide
with different individual member state
strategies
the funding by the eu will be used to
push chip foundries on european soil by
encouraging manufacturers like tsmc and
intel
to build fabs in europe also it will
likely coincide in boosting talent for
making advanced semiconductors
by working with already existing
research institutes like fraunhofer in
germany
imac and belgium and cea latia in france
the overall strategy though will be to
build an alliance of firm
institutes and national governments in
order to pool enough investment
whether reaching the eu's goals is a
giant waste of money is
honestly unclear some will say that
europe is going to squander money
by trying to compete in a market that
they are too far behind in and that they
should focus instead
on increasing their leverage in the
specialized areas where they do lead
but this is a fundamental tension
they'll be raised with every risky
investment decision
it's very likely that digital
technologies will continue to advance
over the next few decades
and bring with it trillions of dollars
in potential value and there will be
plenty of other future opportunities
for vulnerable supply chains to be
disrupted europe could
of course decide to play it safe but
europe could
also of course play it risky which
definitely opens up the potential for
tremendous waste
but it also opens up the potential for
tremendous growth and power
[Music]
you